now that was an example that you're
familiar with I'm about to give you an
example that you're not familiar with so
let's see yeah I want you to draw a
little set of axes like so I'm mostly
just drawing the top half and not worry
too much about the bottom half that's a
bit of a spoiler but we'll see how we go
now the graph I want you to put on here
is one that I doubt you've encountered
before which is why we're gonna do some
work with it this is the graph we're
going to consider y equals it's very
simple X to the power of 2/3 X to the
power of 2/3 okay so if we think about
this guy what does it look like hmm not
dealt with objects like this before when
you get introduced to a function and you
literally know nothing about it you're
like it's not a trig function which I
know what they look like it's not a
hyperbola which I know what they look
like or parabola or anything like that
well what kind of tools do you have your
disposal to work out what kind of
picture you should draw I could plot
points that should always be your first
go to like I don't know any to do what
to do I'm just gonna put some numbers
you okay and it turns out it's quite
easy to put some numbers into this give
me a number you'd like to put in x
equals 1 sure if x equals 1 then y
equals 1 to the power of 2/3 what's that
mean well what is the power of 2/3
anyway well you could say it a couple
different ways one of the ways you could
say it is it's the cube root of one
squared okay that's what fractional
indices be yeah we know what 1 squared
is and you know what the cube root of
that number is as well don't you what is
that no but
cube root cube root think it's the
number you multiply by itself to give
you what is 1 squared after all it's
it's 1 right what what is that number
there's only one possible value it's
it's 1 right last I checked one times
one times one is one okay so I've got an
x-coordinate and a y-coordinate why
don't we put that on okay I get it it's
um it's Monday morning human brains that
guy okay give me another value come on
something easy
zero-zero is there's an important value
to try out we'll get some intercepts out
of this if x equals zero then y equals
were promised y equals zero to power of
2/3 cube root of 0 squared come on you
guys can tell me what that is that's
that's zero okay so this goes to the
origin okay mmm now I can keep doing
this for a while plotting points there's
nothing wrong with it however one of the
reasons why we don't like the plot
points is it's somewhat time consuming
for very little information like you
don't get much quickly out of this think
about the topic that we're in do we have
like any better tools that we can use
that might get us a better picture of
this quicker maybe we could
differentiate this thing that would be a
novel idea in a topic which has calculus
in its name okay you go ahead I'm gonna
make some myself so space you know how
to differentiate this you know the rules
that can help you deal with this
differentiate that and then let's see
over yet it is warming up already
okay you guys can help me out I've
already started but I haven't finished
we know to differentiate things with
powers you take the power yeah bring it
out the front and then what happens to
the power that remains you minus one now
be careful right 2/3 minus 1 is not 1/3
there's a very common error 2/3 minus
one is negative 1/3 that's a little bit
weird ok this is a bit of a garbled mess
right now
let's neat this up when you've got a
negative power what does that mean like
X to the minus 1 is a fraction it's 1
over X yeah so I'm gonna write this
without the negative indices because
they hurt my brain I'm gonna put that X
on the denominator so I get with the 3
I've got X to the power of 1/3 are you
okay with that dealt with that and the
same time I might as well get a read out
fraction as well so this is two on three
times what is the cube root of x very
good okay that's that's a bit weird and
awkward but I can use this I can work
out what's going on I can get a much
better idea of what is happening to this
faster than just putting points which
will literally take me forever
okay I've got a power of X on the
denominator okay
as X gets bigger like if I were to put
in x equals two three four five a
million etc okay I'm trying to figure
out limiting behavior the denominator is
going to get larger and larger and
larger right if the denominator is
something gets larger what's that mean
about the whole object what's that me
about the whole fraction the whole thing
is approaching zero okay so that needs
as X goes that way right the limit as X
approaches infinity of my derivative
what's that equal to well you just told
me it's going to approach zero but
something approaches zero the derivative
that is what does that mean about the
graph what kind of shape are you getting
it's a it's leveling out isn't it it's
slowing down
does it ever actually get to zero it
does not because the denominator there's
no value you can put into the donator so
you the whole thing zero so you never
actually
become stationary but you get pretty
close right it's gonna really flat now
alright so now I know what's happening
over there where else might be an
interesting spot that I could look where
else could I look how about negative you
let's click on this side okay now when
you think about the limit as X
approaches negative infinity well tell
me what's happening to that denominator
if I put in a number like negative a
million in there something like that can
we can we evaluate that does it make
sense you can write I in fact the cube
root of negative a million I'm pretty
sure is negative a hundred right now
you're a hundred times they give 100
times they give out giving you negative
a million so you're still getting a
really really large in size large
denominator so what's happening to the
whole thing
it's it's still approaching zero right
ah but it's approaching it in a
different way isn't it
what was the cube root of negative a
million it's it's negative one hundred
it's not positive 100 right so this is
actually going to be a positive small
value but this guy down here
owing to that minus sign this is a
negative small value right think back to
your first lesson in this topic when you
get a negative derivative even if it's
very very small what does negative
derivative tell you it's decreasing very
good so it's decreasing over here its
increasing over here you've got a
picture decreasing increasing I don't
know anything else yet but that already
tells me I'm in this neck of the woods
that makes sense change in the sign okay
the last question is what happens when I
get in here that's the middle of the
graph that seems like something
interesting might happen you tell me as
X gets tiny as I get closer and closer
to x equals zero what's going on with
that derivative
I asked you what happened with this got
big you told me the whole thing got
small yeah which is true now I'm asking
what happens when this gets small well
the whole thing will become big so when
you have the whole derivative being a
very very large number like a derivative
of 2 3 4 5 5 million right what does
that tell you about the shape of the
graph like what what's the difference
between say this graph which has a
gradient of 1 and this graph which has a
gradient which is substantially larger
than 1 how would you describe that to
someone that's going to look closer and
closer and closer to a vertical line
isn't it it's got it rises a lot for a
very small run does that make sense so
ok now are usign default virtual picture
right it's decreasing gently over here
over here it's increasing gently over
here but right in the middle something
crazy is happening it's being super
super steep ok are you ready to draw the
picture here's what its gonna look like
what is that well before I tell you what
it is in terms of language I know you
can tell me what it is in terms of
language you know it's going down and
then it's going up so what is it that's
the turning point right
it clearly turns okay but it doesn't
turn in the way that any of these guys
do yeah it doesn't it certainly has
those like nice gentle you know
stationery part of it okay so it's a lot
of stationary point it's not even this
it's not a piecemeal function it's one
function is to find consistently across
its entire domain so it's not because
it's a piecemeal function we call this
object you can add this to your arm your
Venn diagram now we call this object
object a cusp C USP okay it's a custom
to be fair it is a very very
mathematically uncommon object doesn't
happen a whole lot but it does happen
and in fact it doesn't you don't need
something really complicated to create
it you guys can understand all of that
so if you want to put your example there
X to the power of 2/3 is the most common
example that gets pulled out okay